- What is your purpose?
What is your mission with this business?
You have to be unafraid of the fact
that you will fail from time to time.
If you have a knack for something
and you have a passion for it,
that makes life a lot easier.
You may not love your neighbor,
but you sure want to do
business with your neighbor.
What makes a successful leader?
Persuading others, sharing a vision,
sharing hardship, earning trust.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from Forbes Editor-in-Chief
Steve Forbes and my take on
his top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're listening,
if something really resonates with you,
if there's a message that
really holds true to you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put it in quotes so that
other people can be inspired,
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- What is your purpose?
What is your mission with this business?
And if you have purpose,
then money will come
if you achieve that purpose.
And so if you're good
at a certain business,
good at a certain product or service,
that's your purpose in life.
Go pursue it and you'll do a lot more good
than doing something
where you don't have that
particular ability.
Free markets, free markets is about people
and trying to do things with each other.
And if you don't try to
use the power of the state
to achieve success, then you succeed.
You know, the reason
free markets are moral
is because you succeed
by meeting the needs
and wants of other people.
If you don't, you don't succeed.
So even if you're that
Hollywood caricature
of just loving money and the
kind of nasty personality
that makes babies cry and dogs bark at you
when you go down the street,
you're not going to get money, wealth,
unless you provide something
somebody else wants.
What's the difference between us
and people of the Stone Age?
Basic difference is we
have more knowledge.
That's the basic difference.
Even if you suffer physical catastrophe,
tsunamis, wars,
if knowledge is not destroyed,
you can come back again,
rebuild, and move forward.
And knowledge comes from
constant experimentation,
what Thomas Edison called trial and error.
And that's why out in the world,
you have to be unafraid of the fact
that you will fail from time to time.
It's never a smooth path.
And you'll be jostled.
You'll get crisis you didn't anticipate.
It's part of learning.
And also failure does not mean
nothing good comes from it.
None of you are old enough,
but back in the '80s and '90s,
Apple came out with a new product,
late '80s, early 1990s,
called the Newton.
It was a handheld device.
It flopped in the marketplace.
But the technology in that failure
laid the basis for Steve
Jobs in the future,
for the iPad, iPhone, iPod.
What we might call it noble failure,
learning from what doesn't work,
experimentation, searching.
If you are an entrepreneur
who's done something,
well, money means you've provided
a product or service
that other people want.
So you're getting resources in return.
And it's not a matter of having
more than three meals a day
or five meals or whatever satisfies you.
- Right.
- It's how you
reinvest those resources.
Like Warren Buffett, long ago,
he had more than he could ever use
in terms of a material sense.
But by reinvesting smartly,
increasing capital,
he made it possible for pension
funds to increase in value,
shareholders to have increased value,
companies to be able to expand.
How do a lot of people get rich?
In Hollywood movies, you do
it by killing your customers,
polluting water and
all that kind of thing.
But in the real world,
it's often having faith in the future,
putting together teams who work together,
and you take it,
you're the last one that gets rewarded.
You got to pay your
workers, pay your suppliers,
keep your creditors happy,
your financiers happy,
and then if it works,
then you get something.
But otherwise, you're last in line.
And one of the things about,
we discuss in the book about free markets
is contrary to Hollywood imagery,
most novelist's imagery,
including occasionally
F. Scott Fitzgerald,
who had something of a
chip on the shoulder,
is that in terms of free markets,
it does develop faith in the future.
If you didn't have faith in the future,
you would just be living for the moment.
And so it does bring about
and it reduces barriers to humanity.
What is it you are trying to do?
And if you remind yourself of what is it
you're trying to do,
especially in the business world
where things are so changing so rapidly,
if you remind yourself
of what your goal is,
then you don't get quite
as upset or disoriented
when the means or the tools
to achieve that goal change.
Well, everyone has knack for something.
Doesn't mean you're going to,
if you love tennis,
doesn't mean you're
going to go to Wimbledon,
or you have a knack for software writing
you're going to become
Bill Gates or something.
But if you have a knack for something
and you have a passion for it,
that makes life a lot easier,
where a job actually doesn't just mean
meeting the needs of life,
but something you look
forward to each day,
something where you
feel you have a purpose,
you're doing something well.
That gives you the intangibles
that makes life just more than
looking for the next weekend.
You may not love your neighbor,
but you sure want to do
business with your neighbor.
And we take it for granted,
not to digress too much from the question,
but we take it for granted in this country
that if you start something,
you want to get the best people possible.
You get as much talent as you can.
And that's fairly new in human affairs.
Wasn't till very recent times
you trust anyone beyond
your immediate family
or your village or ethnic group.
Just couldn't do it.
But commerce does break
down those barriers
and have people interact in ways
that wouldn't have happened otherwise.
And we see it in the global
economy we have today.
Hugely complex supply chains.
- How did you develop your understanding
of economics and economic policy?
- Just a fascination with it.
Economics is people, markets, people.
When they talk about impersonal markets,
that's usually code for you don't like
what people are doing.
And so how do you have systems,
going back to our founders,
Alexander Hamilton, Ben
Franklin and others.
We all have innate ambitions, energies,
some good, some not so good.
So how do you channel
these innate energies
in a way that is constructive,
that is not zero-sum?
That's what commerce is all about.
Your success is other people's success.
In terms of leadership itself,
while times and circumstances change,
human nature does not change.
The essence of leadership,
the characteristics that
make for success and failure
or success leading you into failure,
those characteristics do not change.
What makes a successful leader?
Persuading others, sharing a vision,
sharing hardship, earning trust.
Those things remain the same.
My one lesson I'll give you
today on the facts about today.
The world, especially now,
needs a global currency.
Stability, standard measure of value.
If you ever find yourself in an airplane,
you want a little bit of elbow room,
start talking to your seatmates
about monetary policy.
You'll have all the room you want.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Arthur Robinson Jr. asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in the next top 10,
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know what was
your favorite message from this video.
What did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Bo Hawkins.
Bo, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting
the review on Twitter.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support, man,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- Take for example
cellphones or handhelds,
whatever we call 'em today.
So the first one 30 years ago,
big as a shoebox.
(audience laughing)
Battery life 40 minutes.
The first one out of Motorola, $3,995.
Today, they're everywhere.
They do everything except maybe grow hair.
Maybe they'll do that on the next round.
It's amazing.
Everyone can afford it.
Seven billion around the world.
The whole world is now at your fingertips.
We're so spoiled that if we call Mongolia
and it takes more than five seconds,
we say what a lousy service business.
(audience laughing)
It's amazing.
But these kind of miracles
become commonplace
when entrepreneurs are
allowed to do great things.
We all benefit from it.
What Lincoln talked about,
the opportunity to
improve our lot in life,
that's what makes this country great.
It doesn't matter where you're from,
what you've done before.
You can do great things.
- If the message is true,
if we can really have our wishes,
if dreams do come true,
and theirs certainly isn't.
They get up every day and go
do something they don't enjoy
with people they don't respect
for money that's not sufficient.
What would be their first step
toward going from where they
are to where they want to be?
- Well, if they have the opportunity
is to step back and say okay,
if I had a blank sheet of paper,
what would I be doing each day?
And don't say nothing,
'cause that's the
hardest job in the world.
Figure out what you have a passion for
and being willing to apply the discipline
to achieve that passion.
When we go to a sporting
match, for example,
we see the end result of people,
many people who've done a lot of sweat,
a lot of training,
a lot of passion to
achieve their abilities,
but we don't see all the work
that goes behind the scenes.
So if you're not prepared
to deal with the grunt work,
the scut work, the discipline,
and that's why it's often said
people who work hard in
terms of a disciplined way
end up being freer than those
who don't have to do anything,
because then they can't do anything.
A number of years ago,
a fellow named George Mitchell in Texas
had a natural gas company, not a big one,
and he noticed something
that everyone else noticed,
and that is this country is
running out of natural gas.
So he asked his engineers,
can't we find a way to
get it out of shale?
We have a lot of shale,
tons of shale around the world,
so can we get it out?
And the engineers said no way.
Just not economical.
And he pushed it.
He put his own money into research,
and ultimately, the breakthrough came,
and now we're drowning in natural gas.
Natural gas is $2 or $3.
In Europe, it's $12, $13 for
about a million thermal units.
And the amazing thing is, thousand keep,
the amazing thing is,
it's not only means we're going
to have cheap energy again.
Not only in a few years we will be
exporting energy in a major way.
The government doesn't stop it.
Not only does that mean
we're not going to have,
we're going to have less diesel,
which is not great for the environment,
we'll be able to do trucks on natural gas,
but also change the
geopolitics in the world.
One of the biggest natural gas producers
up till now has been Russia.
They have Western Europe, as they say,
by the short hairs,
because Western Europe's
dependent on natural gas.
Big chunk of it comes from Russia.
Well, if natural gas is
easy to get and cheap,
then there goes Russia's leverage.
There goes the Middle East's leverage,
because this energy's everywhere
if you're allowed to find it.
So one entrepreneur whose
name nobody knows today
outside of the energy industry
is profoundly changing lives.
This year, because of the fracking,
American households are going
to spend $12 billion less
on natural gas to heat
their homes this winter
than they would've if
Mitchell hadn't invented,
come up with, he and his engineers
come up with fracking.
So, and it's just beginning.
It's just beginning.